pregnant Kate Middleton is festive in  green during st. Patrick's Day the 35  year old Duchess of Cambridge and her  hubby Prince William made their annual  appearance at the st. Patrick's Day  Parade in West London on Saturday the  Royal pair visited the first Battalion  Irish Guards looking dapper as ever  Kate stunned in a long forest-green  Catherine Walker coat with black velvet  trim a matching Gina foster Maribel  fascinator hat black tights and suede  pumps spas father cut prints of a  pattern while Prince William who is a  colonel of the Irish Guards or his  uniform for the occasion the couple  later stopped for a celebratory glass of  Guinness and Kate opted for water as the  Duke and Duchess of Cambridge will  welcome their third child together  later this year  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]